[Music]
today's question comes from brian in
texas brian asked i'm 27 years old with
a bachelor's degree in accounting and 40
000 in debt 28k in student loans and 13
000 in credit cards
have a full-time job making 41 grand a
year and live at home
they i'm assuming it's his parents want
me to stay with them as long as possible
because they are as long as possible
because they are enablers
i want to move out and i ask them to set
a deadline for when i have to move
okay they are giving me until february
of 2023. this is so backwards i don't
have any money saved because i've been
throwing it all the debt is it wise to
stay with my parents till i'm debt free
or save up and move out while continuing
to pay off debt
yeah there's a lot of
[Music]
things happening backwards here
yeah it's really usually parents throw
the kids out the kids don't ask the
parents to throw them out that's a
little backward yeah well it's like mom
and dad are saying we want you to stay
with us forever and then he says no give
me a date when i have to be gone and
they're like okay a year
and he's like yeah
i get it dude brian listen if you were
here with us we'd all be laughing and
you know that we'd be laughing here's
the thing um save up some money and get
an apartment
or yeah
i mean yeah
give out and
i don't know why you only make forty one
thousand dollars a year with a degree in
accounting
yes
your job sucks
you need to go get king coleman's book
and look for a better job
um
also you know that's
horrid
um
no you do not need to stay there until
you're debt-free that is not a guideline
um yes it would be mathematically more
efficient i will tell you from personal
experience brian that
i observed
each of my children after college
either
setting up house on their own so to
speak
um
or one of them actually moved and lived
with us for about three months and then
with the game plan to move out very
quickly
but in every case when they moved out
and had to buy their own milk
had to pay their own light bill or the
electricity got cut off
had to buy groceries or there was
nothing in the refrigerator had to do
laundry or there was no clean underwear
in every case when they did had to do
those basic
menial
adult tasks
i
visibly watched them change
in that first year they were out and
they were already mature hard-working
good
people
but i watched their emotional
development accelerate
when they left the nest
and some more obvious than others in
different situations but it was it was
palatable
that uh no more checks coming from me
and no more laundry done by your mom
and when they had to pick up that and
run with it it changed everything so
yeah i always recommend as quickly as a
young person
can reasonably get out on their own even
though it does not appear to be
mathematically the correct thing to do
it generally ends up being
mathematically the correct thing to do
because it accelerates you
and you are what creates your income so
you probably even though you might not
associate it with the activity of having
moved out
it
changes how you walk it changes your
swagger
your body language and so you go get
money more often right and uh because
you turn out turn out to need money out
here in the world and so
it's just good and it's good for you i
would tell you i would highly recommend
you do that not in a panic not in a
freak out i mean if you want to but i
wouldn't wait until february and i
certainly wouldn't wait till you're out
of debt i'm proud of him for recognizing
wait a minute i'm being enabled
my immaturity is i i'm you know it took
him till he's 27 for goodness sakes but
hey you figured it out move out and
let's get this thing going
yeah some people are 35 45 55 and they
haven't figured out yet that well
they're like characters in a movie
though i mean that's just ridiculous
yeah or callers on my show yeah
well yeah i mean it's you listen uh uh
an eagle that does not leave the nest
eventually is called a turkey right so
you you need to um or the way i describe
it is if you are constantly going into
the weight room and helping your kids
lift the weight
they are never going to develop their
own muscles and eventually your your
helping them out
causes them it is the extension of the
helicopter mom that's right helicopter
parent
syndrome to just keep them in the
basement forever